there's been a multi year story that we've
been following and into the story of Brexit
and the primary question has been, yes,
will Brexit happen or will it not? Is Britain
going to leave the European Union or are they
going to end up staying? And as I said, the
day after the vote, June, 2120 16 it may never
happen, Brexit may never happen. And of course
we now know that if the vote were to be held
again today, remain would likely win. Although
there are questions of, listen, they did vote
this way back in 2016 for how long does that
vote remain a considered the will of the people?
There are all sorts of questions like that,
but more recently there have been much more
pressing sort of obstacles. The former prime
minister Theresa May multiple times attempting
to finalize a deal to structure the leaving
of the European Union and failing. And ultimately
the question was was will she be able to outlast
the criticism and the calls for her to leave?
And ultimately she left and Boris Johnson
came in.
Boris Johnson, Trump, Ian in many ways, certainly
physically in his physical appearance. Although
that's not the most important way. The leader
of the Conservative Party now the prime minister,
will he finally do Brexit for the nationalists
and the isolationists who want the UK out
of the EU or will he also fail? And so far
it's really not working particularly well
for him. He has a, between having one Tory
MP defect and kicking 20 others out for not
supporting him, he very quickly seems not
to have the numbers that he needs to get to
the next step in the Brexit process. So bottom
line, there has been one defection at Tory
MP who bailed on Boris Johnson's party. 20
other Tory mps are Tories, or at least they
were, but they didn't go along with what Boris
Johnson wanted and they were rejected. And
now all of a sudden Boris Johnson finds himself
and yet another one of these embarrassing
scenarios for the pro Brexit side.
Giving the opposition control of the agenda
in parliament. Johnson is soon going to have
to face those prime ministers questions for
the first time, which can get very, very crazy.
The opposition, of course, is going to continue
to try to delay Brexit and Boris Johnson may
call for a general election, really a devastating
defeat for Johnson. I know that you know,
the standards and the, the, the sort of rules
of decorum and how to political happenings
in different countries can be difficult when
we're not familiarized with the system and
for what the sort of Overton window is for
what we can expect in terms of what is possible
on one side, on the other side. But this is
an embarrassing defeat for Johnson. Here's
video from yesterday in parliament where members
of Johnson's own party abandoned him and vote
to allow a debate to once again postpone Brexit.
And the question becomes, does it seem as
though this is ultimately turning into an
indefinite postponement? Total chaos, breaking
out. Take a look at the first clip.
Yeah, I used to the right 328 the nose to
the left, 301
[inaudible], all that good stuff. Norris [inaudible]
eyes to the right, 328 the nose to the left,
301 so the Ayes have it. The ayes have it
alone.
I know the book be called a, of course going
to all the the prime minister. I think that
[inaudible] the consequences of this bag tonight.
It means that parliament is on the brink of
wrecking any deal that we might be able [inaudible].
We'll just [inaudible] the flow of the negotiations
to the EU and that would mean more more delay
and more confusion. [inaudible] EU themselves
would be able to decide how long to keep this
country in the EU and since I refuse to go
along with that plan, we are going to have
to make a choice. Mr Speaker, I didn't go
to the election actually I'd I believe right?
[inaudible] won an election, but if the house
spreads for this bill tomorrow, the public
will have to choose who goes to Brussels on
October the 17th to sort this out and take
this country forward.
What I love about the system is that Trump
definitely couldn't handle it. And I'm reminded
of it because when you look at Boris Johnson,
the look on, he looked very trumpy and like
I said, but he has a slightly, uh, more wits
about him expression on his face than Trump.
Can you imagine Donald Trump ever having to
handle something like this? I mean, the guy
just literally could not, he'd implode into
under this kind of actual intense scrutiny
and this continuing to build as eventually
Boris Johnson suffering abandonments and real
chaos breaks out. Jeremy Corbin, ultimately
speaking,
there is no consent in this house to leave
the European Union without a deal. There is
no majority for no deal in the country. As
I've said before, if the prime minister has
a confidence in his Brexit policy when he
has one he can put forward, he should put
it before the people in a public vote. Yes.
So
wants the table a motion for a general election.
Fine. Get the bill through
in order to take no deal off the table. [inaudible]
that's very rude. The members, oh, oh Duh.
Well, the older I take to the Charleston of
the Duchy when he turns up at our children's
school as a parent, he's a very well behaved
fellow. He wouldn't dare behave like that
in front of Colleen Hall and neither would
I. They just stay dead. Rent Sparrows. Yeah.
Tricks. Hey y'all
[inaudible]
things are really getting crazy and what's
even wackier is that this was all merely a
debate over what to order for lunch. No, I'm
kidding. Um, but, uh, this, I still believe
in the end that it is a likely scenario that
the UK may never leave the European Union.
If it does, it may not happen under Boris
Johnson. The way his prime ministership has
been going, and it's very early days at this
point in time, and we actually are asking
you what you think will ultimately happen.
We've pulled our audience every, you know,
once a year or so since this has gone down
since the vote went down in 2016. If you go
to the community tab on the David Pakman show,
youtube channel, youtube.com/the David Pakman
show slash. Community. Do you think the u
k will ever actually Brexit? We will have
results, uh, either later this week or maybe
early next week.